a dense forest of pine and silver birch
trees lines the road to the remote town
of verache in northwest ukraine close to
the border with belarus
visible in the distance is the rivne
power plant ukraine's oldest nuclear
facility some people worry that russian
forces could try to seize this plant
because moscow's troops have already
taken control of zapariza one of
ukraine's four operational nuclear
facilities as well as chernobyl
it's nuclear terrorism chernobyl is
decommissioned but it stores nuclear
waste that needs to be cool
but there are power cuts
for zappo
it is europe's biggest nuclear plant it
has six reactors so when russian forces
take it in this sort of attack there are
many risks
reactors can be damaged and things can
go wrong
things nearly went wrong here on monday
after ukrainian troops tried to swat a
nearby attack by russian forces
there was a missile that flew above here
to shoot down an enemy drone
so this is happening here
there are risks
russian shelling also damaged a nuclear
facility in hakeev last week
moscow's targeting of nuclear sites is a
sinister and dangerous twist in the war
that could further threaten europe and
is fueling anxiety here
more than 7 000 people work at the power
plant so most people in this town are
connected to it in some way and nearly
everyone is acutely aware of what a
nuclear disaster could mean
the mayor of arash is an engineer who
worked at the rifne plant for 25 years
he says everything's been done to
protect it
we know how dangerous nuclear energy is
for the world we've seen fukushima and
chernobyl in viresh there's all sorts of
work at the plant and many skilled
people like me an engineer understand
the gravity of a nuclear site not being
secure and controlled it can be a
catastrophe
a memorial in the town centre
commemorates the victims of chernobyl
the world's worst nuclear accident took
place nearly 40 years ago people here
want the international community to do
more to help safeguard ukraine's nuclear
sites so that a grim part of history
will not be repeated
natasha butler al-jazeera
north west ukraine